mark twain né
é um cara não sei nem a cara dele mas é
que uma vez eu falei a frase que eu vou
falar agora acharam que ela era minha eu
senti péssimo por isso mas esse cara ele
falou que tem dois dias importantes de
verdade na nossa vida e e um dia é
aquele dia que nasce de pouca nasceu cá
existe e tem um outro dia que spa mais
importante ainda que é o dia que a gente
descobre por que diabos
a gente nasceu então essa frase não é
minha é agora que eu já pedi desculpas
do universo
eu começo porque eu pensei cara por que
diabos eu nasci e eu nasci pra virar
músico e um cara muito de humanas mas
não sei por que essa separação tão
absurdo assim que as pessoas fazem
humanas exatas sendo que tipo assim
apesar da música sem uma matéria muito
humana ela vem pelo menos pra mim
a inspiração vem muito que uma ciência
exata que assuste afugenta as pessoas
que a física
resumindo cientistas estavam lá né sendo
os cientistas de jaleco para aquela
parabólica em cima da cabeça e eles
pensaram assim o que diabos mantém todas
essas galáxias
eu não estou vendo nenhum mas enfim o
que diabos mantém todas essas galáxias
unidas coisas maravilhosas tipo nilton
já tinha respondido isso que era a
gravidade
no entanto eles foram calculados mas tem
que ter uma força muito extrema para
manter todas as galáxias juntas e
somente a gravidade não é capaz de
manter tudo isso junto e aí eles pude
sentir não sabe o que é que mantém tudo
junto
no entanto vamos dar o nome disso de
matéria escura porque a gente pode
detectar a força
ela tem e essa força que ela tem é seis
vezes maior do que a força da gravidade
no nosso universo têm seis vezes mais
essa matéria escura
essa coisa que a gente não consegue ver
mas que é responsável por agente existir
têm seis vezes mais isso do que as
coisas que a gente ver vocês estádio
então que diabos é isso e pudins pra
minha música
quando a gente ouve só uma canção no
rádio ela pode ser só três minutos de um
cara falando qualquer coisa sobre a vida
dele mas atrás daquilo daqueles três
minutos aquele cinco minutos tem uma
vida inteira e é saindo na rua tendo
atrás de vivências experiências e é como
foi falado aqui minutos atrás
mergulhando e se mostrando por completo
e transformando vida em música é que a
gente vê que aqueles três minutos de
música às vezes são muito mais são as
histórias de vidas inteiras e eu fiz uma
palestra mas na verdade eu vim pra tocar
então vou tocar uma música pra vocês
[Música]
casa cheia o coração vazio escorre do
meu rosto um amento arredio o veneno não
acabou
o a festa esvazio o tempo danos em si a
aaa terminou os amigos que o fim
e que jamais voltou ferido aqui o abrir
e é que jamais se fechou para passar a
lua
o que vence a escuridão para eu tentar a
que é ser
meu coração
[Música]
vou tentar derrubar
efe s a
achei roma subiu novo que atravessam a
eu sou a maravilha
sentava se afogar
eu grito por universo
o meu nome sei
eu e ele vai me escute eu mandei que o
sinal
fumar afirma amy
eu fui neste apronto
esse meu designer
tudo
a sonda água
a ç ã
mais pra ver
quando que a tv globo em mim
olhou pra você
e os que não estão a
i jogos os que se foram
e hoje a ti mensah
onde não existe dor
vou tentar derrubar o que pra me fez
enxergar
e às vezes me mata
que pai ou a nada
como achou melhor
ó que atravessa ao ano
eu sou o mar av
sempre amar se afogar
eu grito bruni mel
o meu leomil show
ele vai me escutar banal esfriado
[Aplausos]